[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast uh
thank you for watching I'm excited about
the episode today I you know I always
have this intuition when uh before an
episode just kind of like the feeling of
how it will go and I
I kind of felt like whatever was going
to happen was going to uh take its own
path and it and it really did uh today
on the show is Richard grannon he's an
entrepreneur he's a best-selling author
he's a performance coach and he also has
an amazing YouTube channel which is how
I know him over 200 million views on his
channel he talks about personality
disorder narcissism it's very
educational Today's show went from of
course personality disorder which in and
of itself was took an interesting
direction of course people want to
villainize a narcissist so much but at
the end of the day the conversation had
a lot to do with the other side of it
which is codependency and how it's no
angel either I think that's an important
conversation to have but then from there
we let into
philosophizing which is something I just
truly love to do so we talked about you
know kind of the masculine feminine we
talked about morality and just
essentially what we really distilled it
down to or what he distilled it down to
is that these these certain topics that
we got onto are really more of a
fundamental change from a macro
perspective of what we need in in
society I had such a good time on the
conversation with Richard I hope you
like it please hit subscribe and the
bell for notifications and as always I
love reading your comments so let me
know what you think why is it that you
have to actually have the experience to
know like what a narcissist is it feels
like that's true I don't know if you
think that's true but it feels true to
me people find me at three o'clock in
the morning with Google Search terms
like why is my boyfriend so horrible or
why is my girlfriend like any human
empathy whatsoever so it's usually not
the results of like a happy scenario
that people come across my stuff
is that the way that it has to go to
learn the lesson or are we capable of ha
of knowing of being able to see this
kind of person coming like can we save
ourselves from this abuse maybe after a
couple of goes if you're really sick of
it but that's the abuse you see what I'm
saying like your videos at 3am or would
any time of the day are because you have
experienced something that doesn't feel
right and then you keep chasing the
rabbit down the hole until you go
oh my God that's my life yeah well
nobody's going to want to learn like
about complicated psychiatric diagnoses
unless they're really motivated to I
guess if you wanted to be a psychiatrist
it might be the money that motivates you
or it could be the pain of just despair
and heartache that motivates you so yeah
usually it's only this way I I'd like to
be able to create a situation maybe in
the future where we could teach kids
maybe in secondary school age 15 16
about emotionally abusive relationships
to help them avoid it but um yeah for
now I think this is about as good as it
gets it's definitely educational once
you've had the experience but it's the
you know but the experience is so
difficult in and of itself what is it
that attracts someone like what is it
that attracts one person to a narcissist
or what is it that attracts a narcissist
to someone like or what is that Dynamic
what is that magic potion that attracts
the two together uh they they can have
something you know they might be
physically beautiful or intellectually
amazing or very skilled or very creative
at something or at least they do a good
job of convincing you that they are
um when I used to coach people which I
haven't done for a couple of years but
the majority of people I found when I
was coaching them were usually at some
sort of a Crossroads or a crisis in
their lives so they weren't
usually comfortable when they began the
narcissistically abusive relationship
they were in some ways isolated from
friends or family maybe they started in
a new city or a new country and they're
a little bit lonely and they were
craving intimacy as we all crave we all
want to be seen we all want
companionship and to be loved and and to
connect
um and so you know it's it's from where
I'm sat after you know like it's a
decade now of looking at this I'm not
surprised that people get into
narcissistic at the abusive
relationships at all I wouldn't
pathologize
people who get into narcissistically
abusive relationships will say there's
something intrinsically wrong with them
um these people are sort of a type of
psychopath they're moral degenerate and
they don't care about hurting others in
order to get what they want so it's like
being the victim of a crime in a way so
is anyone safe from them or is it
meaning like is there are they just
always attracted to let's say
classically like an empath or somebody
very empathic that
um you know will take care of all their
needs because a narcissist has endless
needs
um or is it or is is everyone fair game
for them for the most part does a
narcissist end up with the narcissist
very often I mean it seems like that
happens from time to time I don't think
everybody's equally vulnerable I think
um if you're stable
um and I don't mean to suggest that
people who get involved with narcissists
are mentally unstable but if your
lifestyle is stable if you're
emotionally regulated
if there aren't massive gaps in your
therapeutic process or your emotional
maturation that have not yet been filled
in and I mean massive gaps then you
wouldn't
you wouldn't fall for it it's always a
con and uh the target needs to want to
believe they have to want to believe so
no a lot of people won't put up with it
and they won't end up with a
narcissistically abusive partner so no
not everybody is is up for it
um very frequently you're right A lot of
people who are very overgiving
codependent phone responder types as
defined by a Pete Walker out there in
San Francisco a psychotherapist called
Pete Walker he calls it the phone
response so somebody is very very
supplicatory and submissive and fawning
and people pleasing
then that can be a common combination
because that people pleaser will
probably have got that from childhood
probably from a dominating demanding
mother or a very emotionally distant
father and then they'll play that
relationship out again in adulthood but
not always not always we shouldn't you
know I've got to be careful not to
encourage people to make simple models
of this because it's not a it's not a
very simple situation what is it that
creates it because it's interesting it
always like I find this I I contemplate
a lot of things about reality and one of
like one of which is are we a simulation
and it sure sometimes feels like it when
you think about the pattern of a
narcissist because they don't know they
are most of the time but they're all the
same they might Express slightly
different through being like covert or
over but generally speaking you're like
oh wow there it is yep that's why you
can look at the top 10 you know hit list
of what to look out for and they fall
into it so but what is it that actually
um creates this personality disorder
within someone
and the model that I worked from that I
came up with a back in 2015 as a
reasonably good working model is that
the narcissist is
raised in an environment where they
split between two polarities of delusion
so they'll be told by parents who are
traumatized and personality disordered
who engage in something called splitting
where a person is split off into
entirely good or entirely bad parts
and they do that with the The Narcissist
to be so the child is trapped between
two pillars one pillar says you're the
worst of the worst you're demonic and
the other pillar says you're the best of
the best and you're Angelic of course
neither is true they're a child they're
not demons or angels in their their
demonic pillar nothing you ever do is
good enough you can't do right for doing
wrong and in the Angelic pillar
everything you do is right no matter how
awful it is will always be on your side
the child is not receiving any authentic
love they never seen they're objectified
they're instrumentalized and they're
trapped and they're pulled apart between
these two poles
of course they gravitate to the pole
that hurts them the least that causes
them the least shame and um desire to
self-negate which is the Angelic one so
nothing I do is ever wrong nothing I do
is a wrong but they're split so both
these are delusional so the way to
understand the narcissist is a highly
traumatized child who lives in a
pathetic break from reality in childhood
and instead of recovering from it they
just live inside of that psychotic break
they create their own
environment that keeps them broken
effectively they they remain on they
walk on broken legs for the rest of
their lives
my understanding of of the narcissist is
generally that um a lot more towards the
demon side the nothing that they do is
right and that um you know they end up
having to go they have so much shame
that they create this facade so that
they can feel better about themselves
but really they hate themselves because
they've been taught nothing's ever good
enough
um what is it what is that other side
that's that's where either a parent an
adult or an institution
effectively spoils them effectively
tells them that they're wonderful and
they're amazing
our views around childhood trauma are
rigid
um honestly like generally speaking
within our troll within our culture
um between America Canada and the United
Kingdom so we think of childhood trauma
as just abuse it's just abuse but
spoiling is also abuse
putting children on pedestals is also a
form of abuse because they're no longer
a child they're now objectified and
what's really happening when we spoil a
child is it's not about the child it's
about us so it's a narcissistic
um way of relating to children it's
really controversial area this like it
really upsets people like I love
spoiling children I love spoiling my
nieces and nephews and in the case of my
narcissistic ex-husband he wasn't
spoiled at all it's false something
somewhere somebody taught them that they
were entitled to a special level of
attention and a special level of
treatment that nobody else was was
treated to it's very common even in
people who seem to have led
um lives of what externally and
objectively look like just endless abuse
it's there it's there
and we as Outsiders will not get access
to that information so you can't say but
I asked my ex-husband and he wasn't
spoiled he told me he wasn't spoiled
he's not going to tell you your ex-wife
isn't going to tell you your
mother-in-law isn't going to tell you
somebody somewhere gave that child the
idea that they were very very special
and it's usually performative it's not
it's not you Danica if you're if you're
a small girl you Danica are very
um wonderful because you're you you're
just you're just a great kid and I love
you and that's it no it's you Danica or
a great piano player or you're very
pretty or you're just a genius at maths
and through your skill and your ability
you make me look good you make mummy
look good you make Daddy look good and
feel good so the child learns to love
themselves the way the parent loves them
loves them the parent doesn't love them
they only offer them this cheap
adulation when they're receiving
narcissistic Supply from them so that's
typically how that plays out you just
said cheap love that's essentially not
authentic and it's only conditional
because it's how they make them feel
which feels kind of codependent at the
same time
um but can a can a narcissistic parent
does a narcissistic parent always is it
and do you need a narcissistic parent to
create a narcissistic child there's no
such thing as a narcissist there isn't
codependent it's not here are the
narcissists and here are the
codependents that's not how it works
kind of the same they're the same
they're on the same Spectrum it's just
are you abusing and predatory to force
love from people or are you servile and
a martyr to to force love from people so
we codependents are no walk in the park
either
we're not we're not wonderful either
we're also highly manipulative and we're
raised in very different environment
sorry very similar environments it's
just that we choose a different path
it's a different survival modality does
the choice in your path towards a
narcissism or codependency depend on
that sort of
um you're never good enough makes maybe
a narcissist versus
you are a really good race car driver so
I choose this sort of
who who is a really good race car driver
who tell me
I don't know guys
naming no names
um yes so between those pulp uh polls
the polarities I laid out yeah maybe one
is is is given more pressure than the
other and commonly when that happens we
would say oh this his two children and
raised by the same parents in the same
environment the daughters the black
sheep nothing she ever does is good
enough no matter what she does and the
son is The Golden Child no or vice versa
the genders can reverse it doesn't
really matter
um the The Golden Child can't do can't
do wrong for doing right everything he
does is perfect
so so that that can be a factor there
are different hypotheses out there that
I've looked at that I think are
interesting I don't need to know them
certain time the codependent tries to be
a narcissist they attempt that but
somebody crushes it somebody crushes it
out of them so you have to be a little
bit indulgent a little bit spoiled to
develop that narcissistic shell because
if the parent really do or the
institution you raised him really
doesn't want to see that there they can
beat her out of you but the theory is
it's not my theory it's by far smarter
people than me far more qualified people
than me their idea is that that
everybody attempts narcissism as a
delusional role play as an infantile way
of thinking your way out of the problem
but it can it can it can fail so you I
remembered your earlier question does it
only narcissistic parents that create
narcissistic children no but you have to
so there's the there's there's a
personality called
uh narcissistic personality disorder
then we're on the internet all going
about narcissism which really confuses
things narcissistic personality disorder
is a clinical entity it's pretty easy to
detect pretty easy to Define impossible
to cure
my humble opinion
um and then what you have is a
narcissistic style so the child has to
have been parented narcissistically but
that doesn't mean that the parent was a
full-blown clinical narcissist they
could have just been an addict an
alcoholic
um they may have been borderline they
may have who knows who knows but they've
not
children need a lot I mean that's just
how they're made and they they need a
lot of a genuine care and attention and
they need to feel presence now if I
imagine I'm just very sick forget drugs
alcohol or personality disorder imagine
I'm chronically ill and in pain all the
time I just I don't have it mate I'm
sorry I can't give you what I don't have
it's so fascinating to understand that
like the while there is polarities it's
part of the same whole and it's really
just your choice of expression so I
think it's important to understand
because if this is resonating with a lot
of people a lot of times you are
probably more on the codependent side
and you're really curious about this
personality disorder called narcissism
or variations of it so what is so wrong
with codependency
basically saying that narcissism is bad
but so does codependency what is the
abuse of codependency people like some
simpler dichotomy so we could create one
of that I've just thought for you now
you could broadly say that narcissism
hurts other people and broadly say that
codependency hurts the codependent so
they're both maladaptive but the cost
could be outward to the environment or
inward but they're both maladaptive
codependency is originally a it's
non-clinical the clinical the closest
clinical entity we have is dependent
personality disorder but codependency we
all know kind of roughly what it means
but it actually meant somebody who's an
enabling an enabler of an alcoholic and
then there was some american ladies in
the 80s who wrote three big best-selling
books I think one of them was called
women who love too much and all three of
them spoke about codependency from the
point of view of women who stay loves
these women but men as well who stayed
in abusive relationships and that was
called being a co-dependent
I just wrote a book called The Cult of
one hey
um and I I redefined it back to the
original narcissus myth so narcissus is
a Greek mythology he was a beautiful
Greek Hunter
who everybody loved but he refused
everybody but his counterpart in ovid's
version of this myth was called Echo she
was a wood nymph and she lost her voice
she was cursed by the queen of the gods
as a punishment so she could only Echo
the last three words that somebody spoke
to her she could no longer speak for
herself
so I set up like a paradigm that was you
have narcissism which is toxically Yang
and then Echo codependency which is
toxically Yin
they're always on they're always talking
it's all about them that's toxic
we're always off we're always listening
and it's all about others that's toxic
this is more toxic for the environment
this is more toxic for us but we do also
manipulate people we do also guilt-trip
people where ostentatiously
self-sacrificing and it pushes people to
do things that they that they wouldn't
otherwise do plus the sins of the
codependent now that we're on this is we
become bitter because of course if you
give too much and you say that yes to
things you don't want to do you're going
to get cranky and better because we're
hoping like little children instead of
saying I'd like you to do this for me in
reciprocation thing and expect nothing
what we do is we hope we hope and we
don't say what we want you're doing
things hoping for a reaction you're
hoping to get something in return like
even just a thank you you're the best or
I appreciate that or you're so sweet or
whatever it may be
um and also on top of that is a like a
deeper hurt in the manipulation that you
could try and Achieve as a codependent
is that however you feel about me is how
I feel about me yes
and that makes you do things to try and
you know feel better but if but it's
fleeting because it's inconsistent
because it's not you so yeah that makes
perfect sense that the narcissist will
essentially hurt outside of them more
than a codependent a codependent
continues to abandon themselves
over and over again and what they really
want and that's what makes them not real
either to some degrees because you know
like I don't know if this is something
you struggle with but I remember
starting to ask myself the question what
do I want to do today like what would
make me happy today and you like don't
have an answer at first you're like I
don't know whatever you want to do I
want to serve my master today that's
what I want to do because I'm a slave
yeah no there's there's what you just
said is interesting and it points back
to this key issue with the codependency
and the narcissism however you feel
about me is however I'm gonna feel about
me this is because codependency Echo
codependency we draw all of our sense of
self from others which is kind of weird
it's parasitic and we're not really
being ourselves we're showing up but
we're not there we're haunting our own
lives is also codependent because all of
their sense of self comes from others
the narcissist and codependent were not
allowed to develop a real authentic self
in childhood it was simply verboten so
they never learned how to do it they
don't know how to access it the
narcissist also is in many ways empty
everything they do is for the reactions
they can Garner from other people this
is called narcissistic Supply everything
they do is for narcissistic Supply they
run out of that and they experience a
kind of death they go into real critical
uh collapse if they run out of that
what is an a codependent death is there
an equal and opposite codependent death
that they experience we're more
resilient we're much more resilient in
that regard because so like I said to
you like the false dichotomy um we love
creating twos we have like a two-party
system and there's two Wings on a bird
and we have two eyes we have two hands
we're obsessed I'm sure if we had three
hands as we make everything into threes
so we go here it is here's the issue on
one side and here's the issue on the
other
so I've drawn this comparison between
our system codependence here's a pretty
critical issue and difference for mental
health and this is why codependency
isn't a clinical entity
we're not mad
where when neurotic when neurotic but
not psychotic we're not psychotic
they're psychotic because they have a
they have they have a break with reality
they cannot access reality on untainted
we can codependents are pretty realistic
they can see other people narcissists
can't
codependents don't see themselves very
well narcissists see the codependent
usually better than they see themselves
because there's not much there to see
but our connection with reality is much
better
I've heard it argued that we have a kind
of codependent Supply which is the need
to serve others but I've never seen a
co-dependent that doesn't happen so the
emotional dysregulation I can say with
certainty you show me a person who's
been diagnosed like clinically by a
clinician with narcissistic personality
disorder that's a very emotionally
disregulated person
you show me somebody who's a codependent
they'll be somewhere on a sliding scale
of depression and anxiety but they're
not they're not jumping out their skin
um with with real internal suffering
typically not typically and if they are
it's not because of the codependency
yeah I'm really fascinated about this
this conversation I I thought of all all
the questions I wanted to ask and I
didn't see this coming to like speak so
much about the codependent but I think
it's only fair I think it's only fair to
understand
not only what what it is that um
you know what attracts a narcissist to
some degree but also that it's just
isn't it this isn't a a villainization
game of like oh they are the only bad
ones it's trying to understand how to
heal so that these things don't exist
anymore what is it that needs to be
healed the most like how what is like a
macro solution for this
um my solution
um I'll just say this is 10 years of
just trying to answer the question how
do I get myself out of this and how do I
get my clients out my clients the people
who follow my material my readers how do
I get everybody out of this what do we
do if you start teaching
self-assertiveness and boundaries you're
creating more neurosis and what I've
noticed when people do self service
courses and Boundary setting courses it
just makes them belligerent and
confrontational and false and I'm like
this is that's not it so I took it all
the way down to I think the pself and I
met somebody who's an artistically
abusive first of all I wouldn't be very
impressed by them
I wouldn't be so naive and
impressionable as to believe their story
of who they were
second of all so I wouldn't get involved
with them I just feel like all right
mate nice story see you later second of
all I wouldn't get involved with them
third of all I wouldn't be in a mad rush
to fuse and merge with them if I had a
self because if I have a self
and I have once and I have value system
and I have a morality morality is an
important issue that we have to cover at
some point
it's essential for recovery and to make
sure this doesn't happen again
and I have a philosophy of life and it's
mine
I'm not going to get with people like
this and if somebody slips past the
garden gets in
I won't stay with them and if I'm all
the way in with somebody like somehow I
just fall asleep for three years and I
get married and have kids with somebody
and I am still and I'm that much backed
in into the corner in a battle and I've
got all of that to deal with to get out
how am I going to be able to do it I
must have a functioning self it's the
only way so the good news is if people
come to me now with uh the issue of
codependency haven't been a
narcissistically abusive relationship
I'm like hey I'm not only gonna get you
over this relationship make sure it
never happens again but I believe I can
help if I can take you on the same path
I walk down I can put you back to life
because you're not living and you never
were yeah so you'll actually employ a
quality of life that you never had
before because you weren't a person
before so then you move you don't know
who you were because you you don't know
you so how do you make you happy if you
don't even know you you mentioned a word
that I'm really curious what it means
get past the guard you said if they get
past the guard what is the guard
uh we all have boundaries or we should
do and those boundaries are based on
filters and every once in a while
somebody will get past your filters and
and your perceptual boundaries your
moral boundaries of what you think is
acceptable
um and that's normal the problem I found
with codependence is we don't have good
boundaries we're either very intimate
and close or the person's a stranger and
I was like wow that's weird I I've
figured that out one day with my with
one of my clients we were laughing about
it
um she didn't even really speak good
English so we would do therapy in like
broken English and uh I was like oh the
way you are is you're not a house with a
Garden Path and a gate and a road you're
just a bedroom and she's like what do
you mean and I was like Well normally
someone oh they say hi can I come in
then you open the gate they walk up The
Path then they open the door then they
go in the living room and then maybe
they get had to go upstairs and then
maybe they go in the bedroom but that's
not happening there's just bedroom
there's no gate there's no door there's
no nothing you have a binary uh state
with your boundaries someone I don't
know
someone I'm literally
doing the most physically intimate
things possible with total boundary
lessness and people who live on a
sliding scale of that even if it's not
as severe as that case you can see right
off the bat where that's a problem like
there's you you can't live like that you
have to have multiple degrees of
boundaries and everybody's experienced
that you've got a friend who's a good
friend when they're out there orbiting
out there but you bring them into a
closer orbit doesn't work that doesn't
mean they're a bad friend and you should
get rid of them that just means they
stay in that place where they were
before that's where you keep them that's
somebody you say hi to at the gym that
doesn't mean you're going to go on a
girls holiday with them
so is this indicative of
both sort of polarities
overreaching be overreaching for
intimacy on some level wanting to be
accepted but not ever being able to get
there because you don't know yourself
well enough or you don't love yourself
well enough so it's sort of just this
um it's sort of this Catch-22 that keeps
missing but it's actually a desperate
attempt for intimacy yes it's a
desperate attempt for intimacy and a lot
of our trauma responses are an effort to
control and navigate love itself
so the narcissist and the co-dependent
are two very lonely children they're
still children you can't grow up as a
codependent you're still a kid
so they'll reach out for anybody and
they'll when they reach out they grasp
it's a very grasping both both Styles
have this this style it's very very
grasping people will say oh no no I'm
avoidant or I'm counter dependent you're
only avoidant or counter dependent
because your primary style is grasping
and you got hurt because it's an
extremely painful thing to do with
people you don't know it's just not safe
it's not safe so yeah we have to fight
to individuate to come back to life as a
human being so that we can authentically
show up and know what intimacy is
codependence and narcissists shouldn't
even use the word intimacy none of us
know what it is none of us know what it
is and as culture becomes more
narcissistic and codependent and
codependent intimacy itself is now dying
which is evident through multiple
modalities
what is the what is the fastest or best
path to truly understanding intimacy
bravery
courage you know you have to it hurts if
you've been asleep your whole life we
show up as the weakest of the week a
scarecrow
um don't attack me leave me be you can
attack this false image of me and it
doesn't really hurt me because that's
not really me so I'll never be me so you
can't hurt me that's a child's response
that's not an adult's response to show
up as us yeah it takes a lot of Courage
it takes you know frankly the old
classic therapeutic work you've got to
figure out what you're scared of you've
got to figure out what you're not asking
for you have to learn new skills from
from atrophied muscles that you've never
walked on that you've never used before
like asking for what you want
and being open and humble enough to hear
the word no codependents do acrobatics
and cartwheels at a Master Level just to
never hear the word no that's not an
acceptable way for adults to communicate
and still talk about authenticity and
intimacy we have to be vulnerable to be
intimate and You're vulnerable to being
rejected
good no you know what would happen then
if I was rejected well you'll survive
you know you take your knocks and you
just you just crack on it's okay the
first one will really suck the second
one is not so bad and so on and so forth
it's it's a more it's a more robust and
a resilient way of of living of living
life so what is it that we're talking
about the steps to knowing yourself and
being able to create this relationship
with the self first and and and then be
able to achieve the intimacy because
essentially you develop that within
yourself
um to really know who you are this is
probably not going to be heard by
narcissists right so and they're
probably not going to have enough
self-awareness to even know that it's
something that they need to address I
really don't understand that I don't
understand why there's no cure I don't
understand what the dissonance is that
they have within them that doesn't allow
them to heal I mean it seems like the
best of the narcissists are the ones
that are like look they're out there in
the world kind of being narcissistic by
going
by using their plot by using their
disordered sort of thinking and way of
living to help people right but they're
like I can't be cured I still slip up
you know like why is it that they can't
see and change like why they see
perfectly why should they change why
should they so
this is this is the philosophical part
of the therapeutic process like I love
this part but let's think about this
it's working they're right they're right
it's working just fine for them and it
may as well be to them like ancient
Greek they don't know what we mean
intimacy and vulnerability what are
these vague Notions
I've never felt feelings I don't I felt
rage I felt lost I felt Envy
no but intimacy can I eat it can I have
sex with it I'm not can I wear it as a
Gucci handbag no I'm not intimacy you
can keep it they're fine they have no
interest in changing therapy is nothing
but an opportunity for them to flex
their muscles and stretch their claws
and practice what they do they charm the
pants off therapists so this is the best
therapy you're so good
I've never had so many Revelations
there's never ending supply of people
yeah there's a never-ending supply of
people so since their abuse goes on the
outside to protect them
and essentially on the other side of the
coin the the codependent is hurting
themselves over and over again they
can't escape themselves so you actually
end up reaching a Breaking Point unlike
a narcissist who just moves on to the
next people which is why you see them
have new friends all the time and they
have to keep turning this sort of system
over and over and over because they eat
them up right like they can eat that
Gucci handbag people like they can eat
them up over and over and over again is
that why that's it if it works if it's
the classic grandiose narcissist now if
it fails and they're the vulnerable
narcissist so the classic grandiose
narcissist thinks they're amazing and
largely they get the world to agree
the vulnerable or fragile nurses thinks
they're amazing when largely they can't
get the world to agree but yeah if they
can if they can if they can do it they
don't care they won't miss you they
won't miss you because they don't know
you they don't know who the hell you are
there's there's only an internalized
representation of you drawn in 2D and
crayon by a four-year-old child of you
you will have the experience when you're
with them this person knows me better
than my mother than my father than God
himself they haven't got a clue who you
are not a clue all they're doing is
how did they love bomb the out of
you to tell you all the things that
needed to be heard to buy in because
we're open books and we don't know that
we think we're so complicated and so
complex and it's written all over our
silly little faces and they ask
questions too
like what is it that I should never do
to make sure that this lasts all you do
is tell them the keys to the kingdom of
pain yes yes anything you say Canon will
be used against you is ammunition and
torture later on
it's so true okay let's talk a little
bit of like that cycle like I don't know
if people are hanging in there I'm sure
that they they probably know this but
like explain this cycle of a narcissist
to someone who might not understand yeah
they find you and they idealize you
then you're drawn into a sort of a
covert contract with them through some
sort of bait now they need the bait will
either be money or fame or love or
um access to something it's pretty
demonic you know there's a lot of like
deals with the devil sort of thing like
contracts and all that that goes on once
they've got you you enter into a shared
fantasy space with them this was a this
the shared fancy was identified by a
psychotherapist called Sande in 1989 all
of us have a shared fantasy when we're
in relationships It's Perfectly Normal
but the narcissistic shared fantasy is a
very dark one so the shared fantasy that
you're then trapped in sort of functions
like the Matrix you then submerge into a
simulated reality so life with a
narcissist has a very unique flavor
because it's not real it's a kind of
flight of fancy a foliage that the two
of you have created you sort of idealize
each other but particularly day idealize
you in the log warming phase and then
you're trapped in a virtual reality
simulator of their design so you will
actually genuinely feel better about
yourself you think but what you're
consuming is narcissistic Supply not
genuine self-love so then sadly dear
viewers we become addicted to
narcissistic Supply and in this way we
become micro narcissists it's a it's an
infection you have to become emotionally
literate you must connect with your
emotions again
so one of the classic things I get in
coaching with people is um they'll sort
of cry and they'll go I already did the
work I went to therapy for 10 years and
I'll always say but if you didn't learn
to access and make friends with your
emotions again all of that therapy was
for nothing you must become emotionally
literate you can't live life as an
emotional letter it's not going to work
your emotions are part of you as much as
your hands and your feet are you cannot
deny the existence of your hands and
live healthily nor can you deny the
existence of your emotions so where your
real self is is where your feelings are
and not saying become blindly submissive
to emotion never we should always use
reason first but how you actually
authentically feel about pineapple on
pizza
is who you are
um I'm really glad you said that because
the yeah because you know your your
emotions are not something that you're
oh like especially if you're more
codependent you have created a
relationship with and they are
essentially the root of boundaries then
is to know yourself to know how you feel
so you don't well you're you're not even
actively abandoning them before that
you're just that's just your pattern so
like being able to tap into that is um
definitely a navigation tool out
how was it when you interviewed Sam um
how do you pronounce his last name
vaknan sambachmann yes I like saw that a
long while back and I was like man what
would that be like knowingly sitting
with such an
such a narcissist and he's like out
there he's one of those guys that's like
a self-aware narcissist but still a
narcissist does that feel weird do you
feel like you're always like getting set
up or something
um Simon's a person he's pretty is
pretty polite to be honest with you uh
most of the time so it's it's it's okay
um for me as a business person and as a
professional to do that but I don't
recommend that anybody else engage in
contact with them it's it's very
dangerous he's a he is openly as you
just said admittedly a very very sick
man so people people really should bear
that in mind at all times and and really
keep it keep a distance from him you
really have to know what you're doing to
be in contact with it with a man like
that speaking of contact then there's
the guy uh tutor he wrote the book no
contact HG Tudor yes yeah and he is
totally like I mean he I think he even
says that his sort of activism around
narcissism is being a narcissist yes
yeah yeah yeah no it's uh it's it's it's
interesting like
um the people who are online who who are
coming at it from that point of view but
what my uh like followers and viewers
and clients will say they get a lot
from that they like to hear from people
who've been diagnosed with narcissistic
personality disorder because it gives
them direct insight into into the way
those people think would you like
philosophizing about let me ask that
first well I'll tell you what I like
philosophizing about and I'll I'll
answer in a way that'd be useful to your
viewers if they've been a
narcissistically abusive relationship
okay moral philosophy is very important
if you're in an abusive relationship and
you're looking to get out and then
you're looking to recover you have to
have a very
substantial conversation with yourself
with your pastor with a therapist or
somebody about your moral philosophy and
you really need to figure out we all do
whether you're a co-dependent or not
because our cultures become incredibly
morally relativeistic which is very
dangerous for everyone you really have
to figure out for you as an individual
what is right and what is wrong and I
don't think there are answers I don't
like rigid dogmatic answers I like
asking the question I like to be skilled
at asking and wrestling with that
question like when is it context
specific if it's wrong in this culture
is it right another so on and so forth
but I like to have that that's what
where I start all the what is the mean
of Life why are we here is this a
simulation a narcissist it's all archons
what's going on
oh my god well the first thing I was
going to ask was about archetypes
because I thought that'd be such an
interesting sort of slight slanted
direction to go is like the archetype of
the but I changed my question I want to
know what you how you define morality
because you said earlier when we were
talking we should talk about that so
let's philosophize about morality but
let's start off with what is that what
is it to you what is your definition of
morality
um largely speaking I I think it's that
simple dichotomy of of good versus evil
I think a human being needs to have a
sense of this person or this situation
might be attractive
but it's evil so I'm not going to do it
and I was raised uh Christian so for me
it's that's where there is a religious
element there's a spiritual element that
comes into it and I have to think of the
seven deadly sins you know the sin the
sloth there's rage there's lust
what's the Temptation here and is this
wrong now if it seems to be like it's
going to be really fun or really
pleasurable or it's going to give me
some payoff in the material Realm of the
of the of the flesh like it's going to
make me famous it's going to make me
Rich there's going to be some pleasure
there there's going to be some payoff
there
um but I know that it's morally wrong am
I going to do it or not now if I have a
strong moral code in my body somatically
I won't be able to do it it's not a
question of me going I really want to
but I'm not going to my body will reject
it if I have a strong moral code if I
have a weak moral code it's going to
become a wrestling match between the
Angel and the devil
what creates that code what creates the
moral code because you know you could be
in one culture where
dog fighting is a totally normal thing
and they see nothing wrong with it and
then you go to another culture and there
are pets and we would never do that so
do you think that it's the culture that
you grow up in that creates that moral
code which means that they're all
different depending you know there's no
one code or do you believe that there is
sort of like an inner guidance system
that operates the emotional body that
gives you a somatic reaction to
something where you're where in that
scenario let's say someone could kind of
have that physical reaction somatically
to the dog fight but they you know it's
just kind of in their culture and they
have to deal with it so do you think
that there is essentially a code
that comes through you or is it totally
defined by your culture
I think that when you say the word code
that's human so the humans are creating
the code but the instinct is outside of
us and um I don't I don't have problems
with these moral questions anymore dog
fighting is evil and you're a piece of
crap if you do that anywhere in the
world you're just a bad human and you
you should be made to fight with a dog I
agree so I don't I don't and as I've
aged I've become much more set on these
things
um genital the genital mutilation of
children is acceptable In some cultures
and unacceptable than others so for
example what happens in America is all
men get circumcised there's no reason
for that there's no medical
justification for that female and male
genital mutilation of children is wrong
I don't believe razor blades belong
anywhere near Children's genitals no I
condemn it openly and vocally I would
just condemn it and say no it's barbaric
it's totally unnecessary it's a no
medical purpose we shouldn't be doing it
it must stop and on and on and on with
these issues they they
full there are some issues that I'm
still not sure about but generally
speaking for me it's pretty clear
and it's this is not from Christianity
this came from me I'll be honest with
you as we're at this point in the
conversation taking psychedelics in my
teens but then hanging out in a
churchyard
if it's life if it's life affirming
then it's good if it's life negating
then it's bad generally so and that was
like taking visions of what we thought
was good or bad throughout history if
you if a part of your body got bitten by
a snake and started to rot you'd be like
damn that's bad
if you feel sexual pleasure if you're
attracted to somebody and then you have
sex with them and you experience sexual
pleasure and then you're blessed with
the child I would think that you would
if you're a primitive person you would
probably think hey that was good like
God must think this is there wasn't any
part of this that wasn't rewarding so
this must be good if it's life-affirming
then generally speaking good if it's
life negating then bad that's that's how
I and then you said code so everything
starts there for me and then it's
encoded down from there I'm open though
I don't like to be rigid and and too
dogmatic but I think we do have to have
a loathe moral relativism I think it's
so cowardly I think it's really cowardly
what is it that prevents us from having
a connection with our emotions so that
we can be connected to that two accurate
morality
from a macro perspective what is what is
creating the disconnection or making it
more difficult for us to know
Satan
so okay okay so is that like
you know my personal belief is is that
heaven and hell is right here it's right
here you want whatever's it's the state
that you live in so I'm gonna go okay
you say Satan that means essentially
being in hell
mentally to some degree no yes
um yes and I'm only being I'm only being
half ironic so Satan in in the ancient
Jewish tradition
um that meant the opposition the
opponent the enemy so that was that
which opposed it might and now and now I
freestyle
the life-affirming things he also uh
some Scholars say the word meant the
opposition in a legal case so Satan was
actually an old ancient Jewish solicitor
uh sorry a lawyer you say in America you
don't say solicitor that means something
else we say solicitor a lawyer a lawyer
so he's my
he's my philosophical and and legal and
moral opponent in a certain sense he's
the one who's going to say why don't you
do that and if you look if you look that
now we're a little bit of Christianity
look at the Book of Job
God and Satan were not
hostile to each other Satan flew up in
the Book of Job I'm not making this up
it's there in the Bible he flew up to go
see God
and to challenge him they were homies
like God was like he placed the bat with
God that which was life-affirming in
job's life job had by the standards of
the day like what was good oh he had all
this cattle in a huge farm and many
children and so that was good and then
Satan took all that away from him and
did his love did it did his love and
devotion for God die or not that was the
question so so when I say Satan or or
I'm in a Muslim country now and I've
lived in Muslim countries before they
say shaytan and it's the same role it's
the
it's that which opposes your goodness we
know that there is a discipline
structured moral path to goodness that
fights against our animalistic nature
but Satan gets in the way so our
depictions in the west would often cross
over with the god pan this cloven hoofed
you know due to the that's pan it's
because they couldn't they couldn't the
Christian church was struggling to get
the bloody villages to let go of pan
they're like no we really like pan can't
we have Jesus and pan they're like no no
no no he's the worst thing ever
but Pam was Earthly he was of the flesh
he was he was he was very sexual and
there he was a god of fecundity and of
the Harvest and and the Christian church
had to get to get rid of that because
they worried it would make people behave
in a way that was base that would draw
them back into evil so where's where was
their definition of Good and Evil you
know was it the flesh versus the
spiritual or whatever but I I don't have
answers I just think it's good for us
all as human beings to consciously
wrestle with these questions instead of
watching The Kardashians
brain cells just dying off
um
you reference a lot of mythological and
religious
um stories I'm curious what your
perspective is on religion in general I
think that we are religious creatures
now we don't have to go back in time we
don't have to take on the old religions
but we are dying right now without
religion us our culture our civilization
is not expanding we're not progressing
everybody will tell you that we are
because our smartphones are great but
we're dying we're we're we're not
explain that
that we're dying or that we need
religion yeah that we're dying if we're
dying how is that because you know on
the counter side I'd say that there's a
there's an expansion of consciousness to
some degree too and uh and um some
awarenesses that are coming more into
mainstream mainstream culture that are
progressive that you know maybe you
couldn't have a conversation with
someone about 10 years ago but they're
like okay so what is it that's dying
that we need
the will to live is dying the strength
to live the courage to live we're having
conversations and arguments about things
that we shouldn't even be talking about
we shouldn't we shouldn't even
countenance the possibility of uh
it no civilized country should even have
to take it to court whether children
will be physically mutilated and
transitioned to change their sex
that's the sign to me of a civilization
that's that's dying
um the there is no way that anybody the
most radical person in the 1960s in the
United Kingdom or America these are the
only two countries I can talk about with
with conviction and confidence nobody
would have so there talk about it it's
happening to a guy I know a guy called
Jeff younger
um who's a deeply religious man who his
wife is trying to get his son to
transition his son is uh I don't know
how old his son would be now but he's
certainly under the age of 15. he's
under the age of sexual consent but
apparently not under the age of
consenting to have his genitals
permanently removed that is a
civilization that's dying and that by
the way folks is happening in Texas of
all states that's happening in Texas
it's mind-blowing to me it's it's really
bad yes you're right there is progress
um the extent of evil that we say in the
world now provokes the conversation and
it provokes a pushback in a culture that
otherwise got a bit flabby we'd all
gotten a bit comfy because up until 2012
there was nothing really that much for
us to there wasn't a proper culture War
the culture wars from 2012 2013 onwards
they really really set off and it's
getting very very very passionate now
why because we don't I think we've lost
our sense of ourselves we don't have a
sense that we are good creatures living
a good life however and perfectly now
there's a growing sense of we are bad
creatures destroying the Earth we must
be killed
um and that might when I say it like
that it might sound like hyperbole but
if you if you translate the messages
that are out there you'll see that
there's there's there really is
something to that it said life negating
death cult that we're in the grip of at
the moment
we're talking about a civilization
that's you know on one side going so far
to saying like a three-year-old should
be able to transition genders
um
is there not an can you make an argument
for an equal and opposite side of uh
awareness of
um accountability of
um opening their eyes to things that
weren't so prevalent and known and that
essentially while it does feel like the
negative always feels really heavy
there's actually just as much positive
do you believe in sort of more of that
Quantum perspective of equal and
opposite
well I'll tell you something
yeah I'm kind of I'm kind of a hippie
really at heart I'm not even kind of a
hippie I'm definitely a hippie so I'm a
mystical hippie and uh one of the things
one of the things that that I believe
though even as a mystical hippie as I
have this sense that like men and women
are very very different and that that's
a beautiful thing and that's the source
of life is the polarity between men and
women
men cynical
and belligerent and pessimistic women
uh utopian and optimistic and idealistic
and so now we're having a conversation
as a man and a woman where I'm saying
everything is ruined and you're saying
everything
but that's good that's life affirming
that's the way it's supposed to be so I
want to frighten the villagers into
action and you want to reassure them and
I'm saying don't reassure them let them
know fear let them take action don't I
don't want people to believe that other
people are going to fix this for them
anymore nobody's going to think there's
nobody's coming to save us we can't sit
back and and wait for the people to come
nobody's coming and it's it really is
it's it's an existential crisis it's not
unsolvable good philosophy uh good
behavior this is Buddhism now like right
action right thought right word right
deed we can regulate this bad karma that
we've built up what we have as a species
built up a tremendous amount of Bad
Karma so at a higher level like
narcissism and codependency yes
but really narcissism is evil it's
wrongdoing it's it's moral Injustice you
know psychopath narcissists they commit
moral crimes in the world
and the job that I think that we have as
people who want to see the world get
better is to stop this spin of Bad Karma
that's come down through the generations
and through the centuries and saying no
it will stop with us we won't give this
job to our children we won't give this
job to our children's children we'll do
it we'll stop the intergenerational
trauma we'll set the boundary we'll say
no you started talking about man and
woman and one of
one of the things that I watch a lot of
information about read about curious
about is sort of the masculine feminine
role and another thing that's sort of
emerging more in culture is this
um you know toxic masculinity or toxic
femininity or balancing the divine
feminine and masculine within you uh
I'm curious what your thoughts are
around that if something's sort of
peaking with you and then essentially
like a very fundamental like should
there be roles should there be gender
roles
first question
and that to me is a sign of failing I'm
magic with him what is hilariously known
as the manosphere
um and there are a lot of guys within
there who are trying to preserve
masculinity and I have said to them I'm
very open with them about this I think
that that is a redundant effort you're
gonna end up trying to preserve a
historical artifact and we're all going
to walk around with neck tattoos on
steroids with leather jackets trying to
like make our voices sound like this and
be really tough and it's going to be
ridiculous
the way you frame the question it kind
of It kind of saddens me because you're
right there is this question about what
do women do what do men do how should we
Act
how false we've become that we need to
even ask that we're we're turning into
avatars of ourselves when young men come
to me and they go you seem like a
masculine guy how do I be masculine I
might well you have a penis and
testicles don't you like I can't what do
you want you know if you want to be
if you're if your sexuality is that that
you're gay or you're bi or your demeanor
is that you're very shy and retiring uh
I don't see a null coward as being
non-masculine I don't see you know the
the great foppish English writers of the
past of being a masculine their
masculinity was expressed in that way I
think there's a whole you know panoply
of ways of expressing it I don't really
focus on human beings expression of
masculinity because it becomes artifice
we're very good at sending out false
signals we're very good at lying as
humans I'm interested in principles yin
yang uh if you want to be a very
effeminate man go ahead what I do for a
living is very feminine I'm in the realm
of emotion dreams and archetypes I hold
space for people so I'm Yen for people
I'm their mother in coaching I'm not
their father I'm their mother in
coaching so I have no problem with it
women also have this issue now
especially you know not to digress too
much but when it comes to sexuality men
and women now they're completely lost
they're special native from their own
sexual identities now so they've no idea
what to do their idea of intimacy and
sex is what they saw in porn growing up
and this is
it's useless it's useless it's all
performative it's from the outside in
how do I look am I fulfilling my
culture's ideals of what being a woman
is
just go inside out you are a woman what
do you want to do what do you want to do
you don't have to force yourself to be a
helicopter pilot if you don't or a
racing car driver if that scares you it
would scare me don't do it to fulfill a
feminist agenda but if that was in your
heart to be a racing car driver and you
smelt that fuel and you got in that
uncomfortable horrible car and you're
like Yay this is awesome go
ahead and go be an MMA fighter I've
trained women who are like this we're
diverse as a as a species
there are women who are not playing at
being MMA fighters or more Thai fighters
they were born to fight it's in them I
know it they're not playing sometimes we
get people who are playing but they
don't last they're not gonna they're not
gonna do the training I don't know what
training you're about to do to do what
you did but I bet it was hard and I bet
it takes years and I bet it sucks and
it's boring because it all is right
but that that's that's what was in you
but you're a woman
so I might just do whatever what do you
want to do you're doing it as a woman so
you know Case Case Closed is there a
place for gender roles you ask me again
it's a question that saddens me because
it's it's outside in it's top down let's
stop telling people what to be let's
stop being you must with her with all
this neurosis and this controlling as if
we know what color socks we've even got
on today it's so weird
let's just trust people to be they're
little boys and little girls be little
boys and little girls they're going to
do it differently and that's okay let's
teach them to be good people let's teach
them not to be narcissistic who
if they grow up gay don't abuse your
boyfriend and break his heart try and be
kind we don't teach that we're
interested in teaching these kids to be
kind or to be righteous or to be
courageous or to be strong it's just
like let's rush to force my ideology in
there as deep as I can before my
opposition does that's unacceptable and
it's it's evil gender roles should occur
spontaneously they shouldn't be forced
top down I was forced when I was a kid
to play football and to be competitive
and all that stuff and I effing hated it
I wanted to read books I wanted to write
poetry they should have just left me
alone they should have let me do what I
wanted to do as I grew up I decided I
love martial arts I got into boxing
spontaneously naturally that's what came
out of me it wasn't forced into me
people are too panicky and too
controlling people who really haven't
got their own lives sorted out shouldn't
be telling little boys and little girls
how to live they've no right what do you
have to say about the statistics on sort
of dating hierarchy and hypergamy and
how the how men and women date in
different directions lateral and up for
women lateral and down for men and you
know this sort of like culture where
we're just over it feels like we're very
much over analyzing what goes together
other and what doesn't go together I
really think again it's we're looking at
the wrong things where we're being you
know when somebody's went like
you must know people like this like my
life doesn't work and I I've just failed
I know I'll control Danica's actions
Danica what you need to do you usually
listen to me
why why because I'm not in control so I
have to control you who cares like like
if you're not harming anyone
I don't me personally I don't care
there's I I'm so lazy when it comes to
caring what other adults do with their
time with their bodies like with their
lives like people come to me like did
you hear about so and so I don't I don't
care like if they're not hurting anyone
why don't we why don't we take all that
angst and that Obsession and try and
help people become more healthy and
where there are criminals there are
psychopaths and narcissists let's go
stop them let's be like hey we've got a
human trafficking problem in America
it's a huge one and the United Kingdom
is a terrible one focus on that for a
minute rather than worrying about what
men and women are doing to each other
I'm not avoiding the difficult part of
your question here's my answer will
women seek the resource of wealth from
men yes sometimes some women there'll be
a leading that way for many many good
reasons it's always been that way will
men simultaneously seek the the resource
of Youth and Beauty in women yes why did
they do that a men awful a women gold
diggers because it helps their children
survive that's it Fitness
your your kids intelligence comes from
the man largely speaking Genetically
speaking your kids looks largely comes
from the mother you want pretty smart
kids who procreate and carry on your DNA
what are we doing like why are we
agonizing over this just let people do
it it's always going to be there there's
always going to be a fight for resources
I I often speak on their behalf of
member there is something that that
happens in this whole issue how do we
say gold digger but we don't have the
equivalent for men for a beauty Digger
gold digging is beauty digging it's the
same thing you're going to pursue the
resource of a wealthy smart guy
I'm going to pursue the reason the low
resource the The Limited rare resource
of a beautiful goal but I'm fine if I do
that nobody points out nobody's like oh
or maybe there might be like uh what do
they call that like oh trophy wife
that's as close as we get that's that's
a double standard that's totally unfair
if men are going to do that then women
should get to do what they're doing like
what what I don't really personally see
it as a major threat to Western
civilization versus everything else
we've got going on but we do seem to
spend an awful lot of time agonizing
over this you're right I agree I mean I
think about it a lot you know I think
about the I have programming stuff and
like you know how women that make more
or are more successful or more
well-known or things like that have a
higher rate of divorce or unsuccessful
relationships and you know sometimes I
think you know talking the more we talk
about it the more real it is as opposed
to just letting things be but I I don't
know I it's hard to ignore or are you
saying there's a trend where if a woman
has more resources and is more
successful the divorce rate is is higher
for women like that is it and just
struggle in relationships essentially
okay well because it triggers would it
would it would that trigger a man I I
cannot speak on behalf of all man as
much as I would like to like a lot of
guys like what drink a beer and watching
football and I can't do that so so I I
don't know
um I would think if when you say would
it trigger a man what have you noticed
it triggers him then is it like an
insecurity thing yeah yeah like to be
have I don't know dominance for control
well okay I can tell you how I feel as a
person rather than as a man if I knew
that I was getting involved in a
relationship with somebody who wanted
dominance and control through any Vector
I wouldn't want to be in a relationship
with that person anyway right well I'm
trying to understand what the triggering
would is is telling me yeah
what is it telling you what's your
theory for what's happening right now
what's your hypothesis philosophically I
think that
that right now there's a lot of
um
disorder and
um resolving essentially within the
planet on a lot of levels and I think
one of them is healing the union of the
masculine and feminine within each one
of us so that we can honor the other and
it doesn't mean that we all can do
everything the same we are the same in
every area it just means that there's
there will essentially lead to less
triggering and more of a respect a
respect for for each other
um and you will be able to honor each
other in the ways that you stand out and
you shine and you're great and I think
that it's I think that's what's
happening right now it feels like from
like a philosophical uh spiritual
perspective is that there is
a triggering there is a conversation
around this because it is being asked to
be healed
interesting interesting I had not
thought of it that way
um and now that I'm thinking of it that
way I would agree so there's a lot of
focus on this because it's asking to be
healed you if you were talking about
yourself do you have difficulties in
relationship because you're successful
and guys are intimidated by that uh yeah
I would have to say yes I I don't I
don't know what the solution is I'm just
my mind goes to I wonder what type of
person is getting upset by that I wonder
what type of human is looking at another
human and saying I really really like
this person I'm physically attracted to
them I'm emotionally attracted them
psychologically we get on really well
God I wish I could be with them but she
just has so much money
and I don't want to go on expensive
holidays whether I don't want to drive a
fancy car is really is that what I don't
think that's it like I mean I get it
when you explain the words out loud it
sounds ridiculous but the truth is I
think it's more like it shows I think it
I think it shines a light on what
someone is not sure if they're operating
not really my problem not like I'm a
problem but I am a facilitator of
information
for themselves yes you're
showing them parts of themselves that
they don't like
yeah so you're
I'd suggest dealing with humans who wish
that they'd done more and just didn't
that's not a man who's doing what he
wanted to do because even if all that
man wanted to do was to have his own
hand car wash like that was his effing
just his dream and he had it and they
haven't done what they want to do in
their own lives that so that dude's
going to be unhappy with you with her
with him if he goes that way in the end
he's just unhappy that's just an
unfulfilled human being nobody should be
that in my humble opinion nobody should
be that fragile without us having a
conversation about
the fragility itself like what like so
if I had that guy in for coaching I'd be
like what's happening dude like what
what are we doing here
how could you be so fragile in your
sense of your masculinity or your sense
of self where did you learn how to be a
man what do you think being a man is
talk to me tell me explain because
something is really really off here at
the end of the day this is why I would
say to him you're going to be two human
beings in a room that could be a huge
room in a mansion with an outdoor
swimming pool or it could be a little
apartment somewhere
what are we talking about homeboy you
gotta you gotta explain it to me because
I don't get this what so we're still
we're still in the realm of like
uh the bass like uh we're still low down
and we're trying to do outside in one of
my boys gonna think about me if she owns
more than I do you know I don't know
maybe I like I I don't personally know
where I'm from culturally I don't know
any men who have a problem with that so
in the northwest of England where I'm
from in fact in my family right now if
you take the 12 couples who make up the
closest people I have in my family of
the 12 couples four of them the women
are wealthier than the men and they're
exceptional in medicine in law in
different areas of their lives I mean I
don't have a problem at all they go and
do they love triathlons in my family
they go and run and they play squash and
they they work everybody works we're all
good Irish Catholics everybody's got to
work but there's no problem at all so I
think you might have been going through
the same archetype again and again sure
sure I charge a lot for these uh
coaching sessions I'm just warning you
you are on the clock you're on the clock
I hope I drive a lot of people people in
your direction all right well we could
go on on we could philosophize forever
um thank you like truly thank you very
much and
um I appreciate all of the awareness
that you create in uh of course the area
of personality disorders but
um uh but also this extended
conversation about philosophy and
morality and
um honestly it sounds like just like
understanding your own emotions and
yourself and who you are because when
you live in Integrity then you tend to
live in Morality and and work with life
in a moral sense yes and that
essentially would sounds like uh sounds
like a very big solution to a lot of
problems by what I'm hearing 100
definitely definitely thank you very
much for having me on it's been a
pleasure
thanks Richard I appreciate it thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button